[Musique]
où je me racontant mon histoire mais m'a
raconté l'histoire de rabat après la
départementalisation
fox était un terrain vierge
on était loin de la ville il y avait que
des herbes
il y avait le chemin de fer qui passait
là j'ai souvenir en de cette période
celui de la venue du président général
de gaulle sur le territoire de la
réunion en 1959 j'ai alors dix ans c'est
un gros événement
c'est exceptionnel je réalise
l'importance de l'existence de notre
territoire
sa visite va renforcer la reconnaissance
de notre île comme département alors le
père fondateur savait qu'il était
d'abord marchand de charbon dans un
échec au bout de la rue rachel est clair
c'est après effectivement la dépense
validation il a compris ce que c'est
effectivement la construction
contrairement à ses autres frères
il s'est dirigé vers l'habitat à partir
de là il a fait des campagnes
effectivement les féroé pour couper les
bois pour apporter le nécessaire pour
qu'on puisse construire ça c'était un
progrès extraordinaire parce qu'il était
tout seul il avait sa vision de pouvoir
donner à chaque habitant des maisons
dans des conditions meilleures
sortant de la case en paille sortant de
la case qui sont fragiles qui sont ben
ali à chaque fois qu'il ya un cyclone et
avec les nouveaux matériaux qui la porte
et on a pu donner effectivement
construire construire les habitations
pour la maison aujourd'hui nous avons
1200 collaborateurs qui nous entoure
nous sommes non seulement sol hilarion
mais nous sommes également ailleurs si
on puisse dire dans la région et c'est
grâce à la départementalisation dessous
peut dire qu'on a pu évoluer parce que
toutes les les outils ont été mis en
place pour que la réunion sort de son
peignoir ça c'est les anciens produits
kerry voyez les serrures les tuyaux des
rabots toutes sortes des rabots
aujourd'hui
non seulement existera bat mais existe
qu'une avant apporter nous les
franchises comme laurent merlet comme
les weldom comme les gifi ces sont des
créations locales parce que la demande
était là la demande était présente
il fallait effectivement répondre aux
besoins des réunionnais donc nous sommes
au même niveau que l'europe que la
métropole dans le commerce en tous les
cas je pense que ces jeunes là
aujourd'hui il faut qu'il soit ambitieux
d'une manière générale ils ont la
capacité d'aller plus haut ils ont cette
force que nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui
et ils peuvent en tout le cas apporter
leur expérience leur savoir c'est qu'ils
ont connu ils sont multi culturelle ils
ont une ouverture d'esprit
extraordinaire et je pense que ce sont
des atouts pour le département
le destin la réunion c'est la main des
jeunes aujourd'hui
à une époque on a construit la réunion a
eu deux parties avait là rien
[Musique]